en un tetraedro regular los centros de
sus cuatro caras son los vértices de un
tetraedro más pequeño la proporción
entre el volumen del tetraedro pequeño
al más grande es m / n donde m y n son
primos relativos y enteros positivos nos
piden calcular m más en entonces primero
vamos a tratar de entender qué es lo que
nos está diciendo este problema primero
nos dicen tenemos un tetraedro regular
muy bien entonces un tetraedro primero
la pregunta es que es un tetra hidro
verdad y un tetraedro es un es un
poliedro que tiene cuatro caras y todas
son iguales verdad tiene cuatro caras y
esas son iguales y de hecho son
triángulos aunque quizás debo hacerlo
distinto voy a hacerlo así
aquí tienen ustedes una cara
una cara de nuestro tetraedro
ahí está aquí vamos a tener otra cara
del tetraedro que es también un
triángulo y por atrás se ve la otra cara
y por supuesto la base es otra cara de
nuestro tetraedro muy bien dice en un
bebé en este de traer o regular los
centros de sus cuatro caras son los
vértices de un tetra edro más pequeño
entonces ponemos que los centros los
centros
vértices de un teatro más pequeño
digamos algo así entonces lo que tenemos
que hacer es unir estos
unir estos y ahí tendríamos nuestro
tetraedro más pequeño que de hecho está
adentro de este tetraedro amarillo
verdad aquí sólo vemos dos pero si
nosotros pintamos digamos espero que
distingan muy bien con líneas punteadas
que atrás se ven otras dos caras verdad
entonces bueno esta es la idea del
problema lo que nos sigue o lo que sigue
el problema dice la proporción entre el
volumen del tetraedro pequeño al más
grande es m entre n y tú ya te estarás
preguntando oye pero en principio cómo
puedo yo calcular el volumen de un
tetraedro y lo que tenemos que hacer es
bueno pensar en lo siguiente si yo tengo
dos figuras similares esto quiere decir
que la proporción entre todas entre
todos sus lados de una dimensión digamos
ok entonces si esa proporción es igual
en todos lados lo que podemos garantizar
es que la proporción entre los volúmenes
es igual a la proporción de las
dimensiones de una o más bien de las
longitud
digamos de una dimensión elevados al
cubo que es lo que estoy diciendo
déjenme escribirlo lo que tengo es que
si a este lado digamos a este de aquí
que estoy pintando en azul le voy a
llamar lado grande ok porque es el
tetraedro más grande ya este lado de
aquí digamos le voy a llamar lado lado
pequeño lado pequeño ok por justamente
porque es el el lado del tetraedro más
pequeño entonces si yo considero el la
proporción entre el lado grande sobre lo
bueno y el lado grande entre el lado
pequeño y lo quiero relacionar de alguna
forma con el volumen grande entre el
volumen pequeño el volumen pequeño me
dice que esta proporción va a ser igual
a esta pero elevado al cubo piensa que
que cada una de las de las dimensiones
contribuye en como un factor digamos de
esta proporción ok
entonces lo que tenemos que encontrar es
la proporción entre el lado grande y el
lado pequeño y aquí es en donde uno se
va a poner más o menos abstracto y ahí
vamos a trazar ejes ejes para hacerlo
esto en términos de geometría analítica
no que es una de las ideas más
maravillosas que ha surgido en las
matemáticas
entonces digamos que aquí tenemos un eje
este va a ser nuestro eje y lo estamos
viendo en perspectiva porque estamos en
el espacio estamos en tres dimensiones
ok y aquí vamos a poner nuestro
g x
un muy buen dibujo ahí está el eje x muy
bien y entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
colocar los vértices de este triángulo
en en este plano xy de hecho está este
es el eje x y los vértices los voy a
colocar en este plano por supuesto aquí
me faltaría dibujar el eje z pero por el
momento con esto basta entonces este
vértice de aquí lo voy a colocar digamos
aquí
muy bien este vértice del fondo lo voy a
colocar digamos acá muy bien y este
vértice de aquí lo voy a colocar más o
menos a la misma distancia
aquí está digamos allí están colocados
estos tres vértices y si yo los uno si
yo los uno me da la base de nuestro
tetraedro
ahí está ok quizás esa línea no me gustó
vamos a quitarla
ahí está esta es nuestra base del
tetraedro digamos es todo esto muy bien
y eso es lo que representa está este
triángulo vamos a quitar esos rayones
ahora ya que tenemos esta base lo que
tenemos que encontrar primero es el
centro también bueno hay hay muchas
cosas que discutir alrededor de este
triángulo donde están colocados los
vértices y pensemos que realmente solo
quiero hablar de las proporciones así
que si puedo suponer que este vértice
como está en el eje x está en el 100 y
esto lo puedo hacer porque solo voy a
hablar de proporciones muy bien este de
acá debe estar a la misma distancia del
0 que este otro vértice así que va a
estar en menos 100 muy bien y la
pregunta es en qué coordenada está el
que qué coordenadas tiene este este
vértice
y bueno no tenemos que aquí hay una
distancia de 1 verdad acá también quiere
decir que toda la base mide 2 y ahora
como este triángulo es equilátero verdad
todos los triángulos son equiláteros de
este tetraedro por supuesto entonces
esta base mide 2 y este lado va a tener
que medir 2 muy bien entonces las
coordenadas de este de este vértice pues
simplemente se reducen a lo siguiente
primero en su coordenada x pues se
encuentra en 0 y como no como estamos
sobre el plano xy tenemos una coordenada
0 en z lo que nos falta es encontrar es
esta distancia esta distancia de aquí
nos va a dar su coordenada y que
esencialmente es la altura de este
triángulo y para poder hacerlo tenemos
que recordar que aquí tenemos un ángulo
de 90 grados o de pi medio si lo quieres
ver en radiales entonces puedes sacar
ahorita mismo todas tus herramientas de
los triángulos de tipo 30 60 90
porque este es 90 este de aquí mide 60 y
este de acá arriba mide 30 30 grados
entonces puedes sacar todas esas
herramientas o de plano mejor vámonos
directo a utilizar el teorema de
pitágoras y es que tenemos aquí dos
catetos y la hipotenusa entonces uno si
digamos si esto es entonces de cuadrada
más esta base este cateto al cuadrado
que es uno debe ser igual a la
hipotenusa al cuadrado que es 4 entonces
ya cuadrada si restamos uno de ambos
lados nos da tres y por lo tanto es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de tres muy
bien entonces ahí lo tienen
podemos podemos con esto concluir que la
altura digamos bueno la coordenada ye de
este vértice es la raíz de tres y esto
va todo muy bien porque ahora
necesitamos encontrar quién es el centro
el centro de este triángulo verdad por
ejemplo vamos a pintarlo como por aquí
como por aquí ok entonces el centro de
este triángulo tenemos que encontrarlo y
como encontramos el centro de este
triángulo pues tenemos que promediar las
los tres vértices promediar todas las
coordenadas verdad entonces vamos a
hacer esto vamos a hacerlo y tenemos
menos uno bueno voy a sumar todas las
coordenadas x primero y tengo menos 1
más 1 nos da 0 + 0 nos vuelve a dar 0
entonces entre 3
esto nos queda simplemente
qué bien
no estoy quitando cosas de más aunque
déjenme déjenme simplemente borrar esto
de aquí
y entonces dijimos que nuestra primera
coordenada de este de este punto era
cero verdad simplemente menos 11 000 y
entre 3 nos da 0 ahora promediamos las
coordenadas z para que vean que es muy
fácil o bueno vámonos con las yes es 0 +
raíz de 3 +0 es raíz de 3 y entre 3 es
raíz de tres entre 3 y finalmente las
últimas que son 0 0 y 0 pues el promedio
será 0 y ahí tenemos la coordenada de
este vértice de aquí del tetraedro
pequeño muy bien ahora vamos a encontrar
quién es y vamos a extendernos a tres
dimensiones muy bien queremos encontrar
ahora las coordenadas de este vértice
superior del tetraedro muy bien entonces
eso sí
si te das cuenta estos dos vértices
coinciden en el mismo lugar simplemente
el verde este de aquí está más arriba
entonces vamos a pintar lo más arriba
algo así
digamos que por aquí anda el vértice por
aquí anda el vértice y bueno lo que
estaría yo pintando digamos de esta
forma sí sí aquí conectamos estos dos
lo más derechito si conectamos estos dos
y luego conectó estos dos
con esto estos dos entonces estaría yo
dibujando esta cara de aquí
esta cara de aquí es la que acabo de
dibujar muy bien y bueno podría incluso
incluso puedo dibujar todo el tetra
hidro verdad se ve así muy bien entonces
la pregunta que nos queda es cuáles son
las coordenadas de este y pensemos que
como en la coordenada xy
bueno es esencialmente
son el mismo vértice excepto que éste
está más elevado entonces sus
coordenadas coinciden con los de este
menos en la coordenada zeta esto es 0
raíz de 3 entre 3 y hay que determinar
cuál es su altura como voy a hacer esto
pues eso es muy fácil mira conectamos
estos dos vértices conectamos estos dos
vértices y lo que hemos obtenido es
nuevamente un triángulo rectángulo el
que conecta este vértice verde este
morado y este amarillo de aquí muy bien
tenemos un triángulo rectángulo y
nuevamente podemos utilizar teorema de
pitágoras verdad vamos a llamarle a ésta
a esta altura pues h muy bien y entonces
qué es lo que tenemos que h cuadrada más
esta distancia que de hecho es la
coordenada de este vértice al cuadrado
tenemos perdón h cuadrada más esta
distancia al cuadrado que es raíz de 3
entre 3 nos debe dar esta distancia al
cuadrado pero cuál es esta distancia
bueno pues son son triángulos son
triángulos iguales verdad entonces esta
cara de aquí debe ser igual a la base
así que esta distancia en azul es la
misma que esta distancia verde y que es
raíz de 3 entonces déjenme ponerlo aquí
esto es la raíz de 3 muy bien entonces
si anotamos todo eso en el teorema de
pitágoras tenemos que h cuadrada más la
raíz de 3 entre 3 al cuadrado pues eso
es 3 novenos verdad y eso me debe dar
esta distancia azul al cuadrado que es 3
si restamos 3 novenos de ambos lados nos
queda h cuadrada igual a 3 - 3 novenos
que es un tercio muy bien
y tres enteros son 99 tercio es verdad y
yo a nueve tercios le restó un tercio de
esto simplemente nos da ocho tercios
entonces por supuesto h no es ocho
tercios
así que h h tiene que ser la raíz
cuadrada de ocho tercios ok que es la
raíz de tres y la raíz cuadrada de 88 es
dos por cuatro entonces es la raíz de
dos por la raíz de cuatro que es 22
veces la raíz perdón no de tres de dos
esta es nuestra altura así que la altura
es dos veces la raíz de dos sobre la
raíz de tres muy bien entonces esto está
fantástico porque ahora ya podemos ya
podemos calcular cuál es el centro que
se encuentra en esta cara en esta cara
digamos que vemos de frente y con eso
tendremos esta digamos
y este vértice de aquí que estoy
remarcando y como ya tenemos este de acá
abajo entonces podemos calcular la
distancia verdad que era justo lo que
queríamos calcular y ya que tenemos esa
distancia ahora relacionamos con la
proporción entre los lados y así poder
concluir algo también de la proporción
entre los volúmenes así que nos vemos en
el próximo vídeo